gene Simmons daughter Sophie flaunts her
curves in lingerie and only et has your
first look at the sexy pics
the 23 year old models stripped down and
turned the heat up for her very first
lingerie shoot rocking some seriously
sexy looks from online boutique adore me
I'm proud of the way I look now Sophie
put her figure on full display in this
sexy set a two-tone gray bra with
matching undies in this shot Sophie
swapped her traditional bra for
something a bit more relaxed grey lace
and hip hugging bottoms speaking of
bottoms check out Sophie here flaunting
her assets in this cozy Sleep Number
we're all kind of trying to tell a story
with her bodies which I think people
should be proud of so just how did the
brunette beauty get ready for her sexy
shoot
she tells ET she worked out everyday for
a month and stuck to a pre-measured meal
plan but Sophie admits growing up she
wasn't always so proud of the way she
looked she revealed quote I really hated
my body and I didn't understand why I
didn't look like the women in magazines
but today she's prioritized her health
and is living her best life and we're
not all the same size in the same age so
my Instagram has the same photos on it
that another Instagram model will have
but maybe I'm five sizes bigger than her
but that's okay because it just shows a
different type of person to look up to